[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone
welcome it's been a little while since
we've had
one of these sessions so i'm glad to see
all of you
and as you may know today we're going to
do one of the
sessions in which we'll have some q a
in fact we're going to start with some
of the q a in fact i'm going to start
with some
thoughts about the recent announcement
just the other day
just a couple days ago the nobel prize
in physics and then we're going to have
a conversation
with harold varmus who i'm sure you
know the name if you don't you should
know the name
nobel laureate 1989 in physiology or
medicine who
has a deep understanding of science
a deep understanding of the politics of
science really brings a
fantastic perspective on questions that
really matter to the future of the world
right the things that are pressing down
upon us right now so
harold will join us in roughly an hour
maybe a little less
of that sort so definitely stick around
for that but let me begin
today's session by just making reference
to the announcement that i'm sure you
guys already saw
about the nobel prize in physics for
2020
being awarded to a real
you know a champion group of thinkers
and researchers roger penrose from
oxford who is almost a cult figure
to to people like yourselves
to me too actually right i mean penrose
when i was growing up
i mean i even knew that name it was just
this
individual who could use the power of
mathematics to gain deep insight into
the nature of space and
time gravity black holes in fact
when i was a graduate student i was a
grad student at oxford and i went to
oxford to study with roger penrose
and it turned out that the things that
roger
happened to be interested in that little
window of time when i was at oxford were
things that i
wasn't all that excited about and i
switched over
from roger penrose to the particle
physics group at oxford led by graham
ross
and there is where i got involved in
string theory
and extra dimensions and things of that
sort which
in the end overlaps quite tightly with
the arena of research in which roger
penrose has made
his mark but the nobel prize was awarded
to roger half the prize that is was
awarded for
the so-called the the the singularity
theorem results where he showed that
the prediction of black holes which you
all know goes back to
carl schwarzschild back in 1916.
right schwarzschild writes the first
paper having the first
analytical exact solution to the
einstein field equations
even einstein himself did not find an
exact solution to his own equation
schwarzschild does
and as as the analysis as soursop does
his analysis of the solution it's the
solution for
a spherical mass embedded in otherwise
empty space
and schwarzschild solution shows that if
that mass is crushed down to a
sufficiently small size
then the warpage in space-time will be
so incredibly
severe that nothing will be able to
escape
and this is what we ultimately call
black holes
that name actually didn't come until
excuse me a bit later on
the name black holes as some of you may
know maybe you've heard me say it before
the name black hole was coined on um
112 street and broadway
in manhattan new york city this is not a
joke this is true
that is the location of the it was
location of the goddard institute for
space studies
i actually worked for that institute
when i was in high school doing
research on satellite imagery and how
you can use satellites to
understand various detailed features of
the topography
and erosion of sites on planet earth but
anyway there was a talk at the goddard
institute for space studies in 1968 i
think it might have been
john wheeler has given the talk and an
audience member responding to what
wheeler was talking about says
oh the thing you're talking about it's
like a black hole a black hole in space
and wheeler likes that name he had a
good feel
for marketing in physics and he starts
to promote
that name and that's where the name
black hole comes from and roger's work
showed that schwarzschild's solution the
black hole solution
doesn't require the highly idealized and
therefore perhaps
unrealizable conditions that
schwarzschild was
invoking to have a black hole created
roger showed they're a fairly general
phenomenon
of the general theory of relativity
under very mild assumptions
you will get black holes as the result
of certain physical circumstances and
that really
made it clear that black holes were a
generic endemic feature of the general
theory of relativity
the others who shared their prize
ronald gertz and andrea guezz
they were the first individuals to
perfect means for observing with great
precision
the center of the milky way galaxy
and in those observations they
established that there has to be
an enormously massive black hole at the
center of our galaxy a black hole
weighing in the order four million times
the mass of the sun how they do that
well
you look at stellar orbits i don't know
if we have any visuals we could bring up
if we're able to that would be amazing
but you have stellar orbits
and you watch these stars going around
the center of the milky way galaxy and
they are whipped around
at such incredibly high speeds you know
tens of millions of miles an hour and
when you look
at the center and try to figure out what
is it that has
enough gravitational pull to whip those
stars around
in that manner you find that whatever it
is it has to be incredibly massive to
give rise to the gravitational pull
whose influence you're witnessing in
those measurements of the stellar orbits
and you realize that that incredible
mass must be in a very small region
because you can measure the size within
which this
source of gravity resides and so
when you put those two numbers together
the huge mass and the small
size you come to the conclusion that
there has to be a black hole there
of course we've gone even further today
the event horizon telescope has taken a
direct image using radio telescopes of
the black hole
at the center of m87 you know 55 million
light years away but the black hole i'm
referring to now
that these astronomers won the nobel
prize for
is you know whatever fifty thousand
light years away at the center of our
galaxy and in particular
andrea guess i was actually just talking
to her the other day
i'm not trying to name drop here but yes
i was talking to
the new nibble laureate andrea guezz
just the other day about
a celebration that she's going to be
having for
the 25th anniversary of the
project that led to ultimately the nobel
prize i was speaking to her she didn't
know she
was about to win the nobel prize or
maybe she had an inkling of i don't know
but she's only the fourth woman fourth
woman
to win the nobel prize in physics so
that is a
wonderful well-deserved achievement
and i couldn't be more excited for her
and excited for all three
of these great scientists for receiving
this
award okay so that that's an exciting
moment
in the development of physics that
happened this week
with that let me now turn to
some of the questions that you have and
again the conversation that i'll be
having with harold varmus we're going to
probably begin that
sometime near one
o'clock if you're if your questions
start to run out of steam it's never
happened actually
but if your questions run out of steam
maybe maybe i'll
bring harold in to re-energize the
conversation sooner
but uh have a feeling that you
will not have a paucity of
of questions okay let's take a look at
what we have here
um martin topinka asks professor brian
could you explain to me
why a uniform soup of particles at the
big bang has very low entropy it's a
good question
while structures have higher entropy why
does gravity act this way and what it is
how does gravity and entropy interact
with one another so martin
is a very that's a good question because
when we learn about entropy as students
and i suspect that many on this chat
many on this
video discussion have had some
undergraduate experience in physics but
in a standard undergraduate course
in thermodynamics or statistical
mechanics we learned about entropy and
we are told
entropy is a count of the number of
rearrangements of the microscopic
ingredients that leave
a system's macroscopic features
unchanged
and we're told that in the form of
equations we're asked to look at the sum
over all states that are compatible
all microstates that are compatible with
the macro quantum state of a system
right all available quantum states i
should say all available quantum states
that are consistent with the
macroscopic features of that of that
system okay so that's what it is
now when we start to look at examples
the primary examples
of high entropy configurations are
configurations where
the particles are all uniformly
dispersed when we look at gas in a box
we learn that the high entropy
configuration is when the gas is
uniformly spread throughout the box
and we learned that the low entropy
configuration is say when the gas is all
clustered in one tiny little corner
and we learned the second law of
thermodynamics which tells us that
the low entropy configuration of gas all
clustered in the corner will
typically disperse outward toward the
state of higher entropy entropy tends to
increase
so the high energy state
is the one with the particles all
uniformly dispersed through the box
now that's curious because as martin is
pointing out when we talk about the big
bang
we talk about the big bang having low
entropy you've probably heard me say
this
in previous of our gatherings we always
say that it's the
low entropy ordered configuration of the
big bang which allows
for entropy to increase over time which
allows for
other structures ultimately to arise
if the big bang itself was totally
disordered high entropy
there'd be no potential for the
universe to then evolve toward higher
entropy if it already had the maximal
entropy to begin with so we'd be
we believe that the big bang is a state
of
low entropy high order and yet as martin
is pointing out when we talk about the
big bang we talk about
particles that are uniformly dispersed
throughout space or energy that's
uniformly dispersed throughout space
namely we're talking about a low entropy
configuration
but the state of that seems
to resonate much more closely with the
high entropy configuration that we learn
about as undergraduates in physics so
what gives what's going on here
as martin is rightly pointing out
gravity
is the essential new player you see when
we learn about entropy
as undergraduates or if you've yet
to do so when you learn about entropy as
an undergraduate
there will likely be no mention of
gravity whatsoever
when we first learn about entropy we
learn about it in a
context in which gravity is not a
dominant player and that kind of makes
sense right
the gas in this room the air in this
room right now is it affected by gravity
sure but not that much right because the
particles the individual molecules
are so light that they get buffeted to
and fro by
other forces thermal forces agitation
electromagnetic interactions and those
are just much stronger
than the influence of gravity so we
typically as a first approximation just
ignore gravity in everyday circumstances
but at the big bang
you can't do that at the big bang the
density
of matter and energy is so high that the
gravity is so strong that you cannot
ignore gravity and when gravity comes
into the story
the discussion of entropy becomes a
little more subtle
what we learn is that because gravity is
this universally attractive force
it can take what appears to be a high
entropy configuration
in the absence of gravity uniformly
spread out particles
and it can drive it to yet higher
entropy configurations by
causing some of those particles to fall
together
into structures like stars and planets
and in the process of crushing those
particles together
gravity causes the system to heat up and
therefore emit
heat light other particles to the wider
environment
and so we get a highly non-uniform
highly non-homogeneous configuration
when gravity
is strong enough when there's enough
matter for gravity
to be the dominant force because you get
clumpy things here and then spread out
particles
there and that's the dynamic that we
believe
allowed structure in the universe to
form you and me in stars and planets
galaxies we
are the beneficiaries of that uniform
configuration in the early universe that
then through the action of gravity
clumped up into stars and planets and on
certain of those planets
smaller clumps formed and some of those
clumps
grew limbs and some of those clumps with
limbs
and brains began to walk around think
about things and come up with the
explanation that i just gave you so
that's the the basic answer
to martin's question about entropy
and gravity okay
going back to the the chat here if you
have a question just put it in the chat
um abbay kumar please explain
singularities by i wish i could explain
singularities
i can explain some singularities and i
can explain the generic
the general idea of what a singularity
is
but there are many singularities that we
have yet to fully understand
and one of the most pivotal is the one
at the center of a black hole the very
topic that
was this the focus of work that won the
nobel prize
so anyway what is a singularity a
singularity is a euphemism
it's a euphemism for we don't know what
the heck is going on that's all that it
is
right now more specifically we typically
talk about singularities in the general
theory of relativity although not
exclusively
and in the general theory of relativity
there are certain mathematical solutions
to einstein's equations
where the curvature of space time blows
up
it soars toward infinity it's a
curvature that approaches one divided by
a number that itself approaches zero so
the curvature approaches one divided by
zero which of course is
infinite put one divided by zero in a
calculator
it says error or infinity or something
like that
so that's what a singularity is now why
do we call them out we call them out
because they're meaningless they're
mathematically meaningless
infinity is not just a big number
infinity is a number that in certain
contexts
we understand when we talk about the
natural numbers
going up to infinity yeah we sort of
understand that well when we talk about
the real numbers going to infinity we
pretty much
have that under control but when we talk
about a curvature of a space going to
infinity that's like having
infinitely curved part of space
a kink in it or a location where
it no longer looks like a smooth
environment which is what
general relativity requires for physics
to make sense
so a singularity in the general theory
of relativity is a diagnostic
it's a mathematical tool that
assures us that something deep is wrong
so what we try to do is cure
singularities we try to make sense of
them and for instance some of the work
that i've done
some of the most fun work that i've done
was going beyond the general theory of
relativity into string theory
that combines general relativity and
quantum mechanics
and in that setting we found
that certain singularities that
einstein's theory could not cope with
the math of string theory could cope
with in other words the infinity of
general relativity
was tamed into a finite value a finite
number
and that is generally what we view as a
success story
where a new theory goes beyond a
previous theory
and allows you to address things that
the previous theory
was impotent to address couldn't address
at all but when it comes to more
exotic singularities than the ones that
we have been so far able to handle
like the singularity at the center of a
black hole or the singularity of the big
bang nobody has really
convincingly figured out how to resolve
those
singularities and so those are open
questions
what truly happens at the center of a
black hole
what truly happened at the moment of the
big bang
we'd like to get to a point where we
don't just shrug
and that's the goal of a lot of the
cutting edge research that's going on
today
all right what do we all have here why
does time only move
in one direction somebody asked that
question but it scrolled by too quickly
so i don't know who who asked that
question so
sorry about that i should keep my
fingers off the chat every time i touch
it it scrolls too fast
um all right why i'll answer the
question is why does time
only go in one direction again we only
have partial answers
entropy which martin asked about earlier
is part of that answer
we believe that although the laws of
physics are agnostic about
past and future they treat past and
future in exactly the same way
completely symmetrically
even though the equations don't care
about what we
humans call past and future entropy
this measure of disorder does
have a bias it does increase toward
the future so if you anchor entropy
at the beginning of time call that the
big bang if it's anchored at a low value
then entry people typically have a graph
that just goes upward now and then it
can come down it's not an iron-clad law
of the second law of thermodynamics it's
a tendency
but that tendency is so overwhelming
that indeed
entropy toward the future goes
up and so that's part of the answer
but is it a full answer i don't consider
it a full answer for instance
i can't answer the question why was
entropy low
at the big bang now some would say maybe
that's not even a question
worth thinking about it's just an
environmental
detail an environmental quality of the
universe and you just accept it
for whatever reason it just happens to
be
that that's how the universe began but
we physicists
how we don't like answers like that
we're not satisfied by answers that
are just so stories we want to find deep
fundamental principles and many people
have
worked on the question of why the early
universe had low entropy
i wrote a paper a couple years ago that
i thought was kind of fun
in the end i don't think it actually
works but it goes back
sorry to keep referring back to you
martin but your question
has proved to be pivotal and a lot of
what i'm talking about right here but
martin's question
we were led to talk about gravity and
entropy and noted that when gravity is
part of the story entropy has different
qualities so imagine
that in the very early universe there
was no gravity
and so the uniformly distributed
particles
would have been the natural state of
being it would have been the state of
high entropy in the absence of gravity
and then imagine that somehow a flip
not a flip a switch is flipped not a
flip is switched a switch is flipped
a switch is flipped and gravity turns on
and then when gravity turns on my answer
to martin's question comes into play
things start to clump together and you
reach a yet higher entropy
disordered non-homogeneous state of
being
and that could be an answer it turns out
that in the
flipping of the switch there are
entropic considerations too that you
need to think about
that wind up suggesting strongly that
the resolution that i just described is
really assuming
the answer i don't know if there's some
version of that story that could work
but
suffice to say people still think deeply
about this question
and i don't know the answer to it okay
um let's see
uh yeah back to a black hole since that
seems to be a good topic for this
nobel prize announcement week so kuchal
asks what is inside a black hole what is
it
actually and i love the questions that
are coming today they also make me feel
a little
less than sage like because many of
these questions
i cannot give you the full answer to but
i can
at least give you the state of play the
state of the art
so in einstein's general theory of
relativity the inside of a black hole
nothing particularly special so by
inside i assume you mean
inside the so-called event horizon of
a black hole now in einstein's theory
the event horizon is not some
[Music]
unusual place in the sense of there's
something
measurably different about being at the
event
horizon you and i could just now
have crossed over the event horizon of a
really large black hole
and we would not have known it that
could be what's going on we could right
now
be heading toward doom heading toward
the center of that black hole
where we will be crushed out of
existence and we would not have known
that we crossed
over the edge of that black hole there's
no sign
post in space that says warning event
horizon beyond this point it doesn't
work that way the event horizon
is an absolutely ordinary
prosaic location in space from the
perspective of someone who
is passing by that location and that
hints
at the answer to your question because
if the event horizon
isn't some special sign posted location
then when you cross over the event
horizon the space that you encounter
will pretty much
be like the space that you were just
passing through
so the inside of a black hole inside the
event horizon
looks pretty much like the outside of
an event rise and it's just empty space
and you only really notice
something unusual happening when you get
closer and closer and closer to the
center
of the black hole where the tidal forces
that is
the strength of gravity on your feet if
you're following feet first
versus the strength of gravity on your
head will be much stronger on your feet
than on your head so your body
will be under tension tidal force
tension your feet will be pulled
downward toward the center of the black
hole
with a greater force than your head
which is a little further away
from the center and you will be what we
call spaghettified
spaghettified that's a technical term
of art which says that you will be
stretched more
and more to look like a piece of
spaghetti
and ultimately you will be pulled apart
into your constituent particles
but in this classical description the
inside of the black hole
other than the uncomfortable nature
of being near the center other than that
it'll look like
space pretty much anywhere else now
when we have tried to put quantum
mechanics in this story
that classical description has
undergone various proposed revisions
and we're not sure which proposed
revision is
necessarily right or if any of them my
my friend samir mather wonderful
physicist
at ohio state university we were
postdocs together in the early days
back at back at harvard in the 1980s or
something
and he has proposed that black holes are
actually
big entangled balls of strength
and that's a very different picture of a
black hole he's saying that we
have long been confused by the pure
classical
einstein description of black holes and
he says that there may not even be
an event horizon he thinks a black hole
is sort of more like a star
it's got stuff in it like a star
and the stuff is this big and tangled
ball of strings so he calls these fuzz
balls
so samir suggests that black holes
should
be replaced by fuzzy things called fuzz
balls
others have suggested that the event
horizon
of a black hole may be a location
of extreme temperature this is called
the firewall
picture that emerged from a paper
whose authors are usually referred to
with the acronym
amps the p in there is joe polczynski
who
tragically passed away not that long ago
which is a enormous blow to physics
enormous blow to everybody who cared
deeply about him
but in that paper joe and his
collaborators
realize that there's a tension between
quantum entanglement
and black hole physics and one
resolution to that tension they found is
to
imagine that the event horizon of a
black hole is a real place
that has a high temperature so that
anything that gets
too close to the black hole is
incinerated by that heat and indeed
there may not be
any space on the other side of the
firewall the firewall could be the end
of space in that region and then the
answer to the question that was asked
would be what's inside the black hole
what's it like the answer would be there
isn't
an inside to a black hole and that would
be another possible answer so this is a
a completely open question and a
fruitful area
of research and one that maybe some of
the younger members of the discussion
we're having will one day have impact
on that kind of question okay
moreno san guanini
asks will primordial black holes ever be
detected
and i got to tell you guys thank you for
asking all these black hole questions
it feels so relevant to this week
but again feel free to ask anything you
want but it's kind of nice
so will primordial black holes ever be
detected so first off what is
a primordial black hole primordial black
hole is a black hole
that would have formed right around the
big bang
so often when we think about black holes
stellar mass black holes a black hole
with a mass of whatever 10 times the
mass of the sun
we imagine that there's a star maybe
it's a red giant star
and we envision that at some point it
uses up its nuclear fuel
that's important because it's the
nuclear burning in the
core of a red giant that creates the
outward flowing pressure that supports
the star
against implosion against its incredible
heft it's incredible weight
when the star uses up its nuclear fuel
that outward pushing pressure goes away
and the star implodes in on itself it
gets hotter and more dense at the core
ultimately setting off an explosion that
ripples through the star
blows off the surface supernova
explosion
and what remains is a dense
core that has no capacity to support its
own weight at all so
it collapses in on itself and creates a
black hole
so that's the procedure by which we
believe that
many black holes in the universe form
primordial black holes would not form in
that manner because there weren't any
stars
there weren't any supernova there
weren't that there weren't those kind of
clumps of matter at that point
instead the idea is that clumps of
matter could just
immediately come together and collapse
directly
into a black hole and these primordial
black holes the thought is
might still exist now here's the issue
black holes
evaporate when you take quantum
mechanics into account so this is
something that stephen hawking taught us
in 1974
that even though black holes are
completely black
according to einstein's vision
einstein's equations i should really
just say einstein's equation because
einstein
didn't actually believe that black holes
would be real that's a separate story
but einstein's math says that nothing
gets out of a black hole but stephen
hawking showed that when you include
quantum physics which einstein's math
does not
include stuff can get out of a black
hole
so if a black hole is sufficiently small
then as
it radiates it'll just evaporate all its
heft
we don't know exactly what would be left
at the end but we suspect that the black
hole itself would be gone
so if all primordial black holes have
evaporated
finally to the question that was asked
by moreno san guanini like to say that
name
then if they've all evaporated
they won't be around to be detected if
any have persisted and there are ways
that they might have persisted
then yeah in principle one day we might
detect a primordial black hole which
would be uh
enormously exciting enormously exciting
okay uh session asked please
ask the questions one by one i i can't
do that because they're scrolling by
maybe there's a way in which i could
you're right it would be nicer i guess
to have first come first served on the
questions but
we'll have to figure out a way of doing
that i can't do that
easily right now um
let's see so m5
m5 says i just expected in the first
step you would interview one of the
nobel laureates in physics
professor guez professor panos oh come
on m5
there is an ample opportunity for us to
have conversations
with all sorts of thinkers and at some
point
we will have uh the newly minted nobel
laureates in physics but
if uh as harold no doubt will tell us in
the next part of our discussion once
the announcement is made life as a noble
as a new noble lord is incredibly hectic
so i'd rather have a conversation with
them when
things settle down just a little bit
okay what else do we got here
uh upgrade says if nothing can move
faster than light how does anything go
into a black hole upgrade i'm not
exactly sure i understand the question
because
if something goes into a black hole it
can fall in
at whatever speed it likes it doesn't
have to go faster than the speed of
light
so it's more the reverse story in fact
let me tell you that there's an
interesting analogy
that i sometimes tell my students
when i'm teaching about black hole
physics which is you can liken falling
over the edge of a black hole to falling
over the edge of a waterfall
what do i mean by that well imagine
you're in a boat
right and there's a there's a big
waterfall
right over there and you're like well i
i really don't want to fall over that
waterfall what do you do is you turn
your boat
and you start to paddle upstream and you
hope
that you can paddle faster than the
water is flowing
because if you can't paddle faster than
the water is flowing you're doomed
right you're going to be dragged to the
edge you're going to fall over the
waterfall now what's the analogy with
black holes
there is a real sense this is not
cartoon physics this is a real sense in
which you can describe a black hole
the edge of a black hole as a region
where space itself
is falling over the edge
space itself is flowing over the edge of
the black hole and indeed at the edge
the speed of space is equal to the speed
of light
think about that why is that important
well
if you happen to find yourself at the
edge of a black hole
and you don't want to fall in you're
kind of in trouble right
because you can't go faster than the
speed of light
nothing can no material object can so if
space itself is flowing at a speed equal
to the speed of light
you are doomed and that's why you are
doomed if you get
right to the edge of a black hole if
you're outside the edge
then the speed of space is less than the
speed of light and therefore in
principle you can get away
in principle you can turn on your rocket
engines
and paddle upstream as the
person in the boat would do with the
waterfall but once you get to the edge
of the black hole can't go faster than
the speed of light space itself is
flowing over the edge at
a speed equal to the speed of light and
that is one way of thinking about
why you cannot get away why you cannot
get away
okay all right couple more before we
turn
to uh the main event for which i am the
warm-up
here today uh vinod asks
is there anything faster than light and
the answer to that question vinod is yes
in a sense so so you should bear in mind
that even in einstein's special theory
of relativity the
precursor to the general theory of
relativity that einstein
wrote down in 1905
in that theory the only prescription
is that no material object can go
through space at a speed greater than
the speed of light
and it's important to hear the first
half of that sentence
because just to give you an example when
i say that nothing can go
through space at a speed faster than the
speed of light that
for instance does not restrict the speed
of spatial expansion to be less than
the speed of light so if you have two
galaxies
in space right and if space itself is
swelling
and thereby dragging the galaxies apart
like poppy seeds and a muffin that's
expanding the poppy seeds are
dragged apart similarly if the galaxies
are being dragged apart by the swelling
of space
there is nothing that says that the
speed of recession
of those galaxies needs to be less than
the speed of light
the galaxies are not moving through
space
the galaxies in a sense are stitched
into the fabric
of space and they're only moving because
the fabric of space
itself is swelling and there's nothing
in einstein's declaration
that restricts the speed of spatial
swelling
the speed of spatial expansion and bleed
and and we do believe
that and our cosmological mathematical
theories support this
that objects can move apart faster than
the speed of light because
of the expansion of space so the answer
to your question
the note is yes in that sense
raghav asked why does string theory stop
with ten dimensions
why not more or less than ten
and first off i should say that
just to be clear the most modern
incarnation of string theory
often given the name m theory
involves 10 dimensions of space and one
of time so
11 11 does come into the story
so right there it's bigger than 10 if
you were referring to space time
but there are what are known as
non-critical
string theories in which it's a little
subtle
but in a time dependent scenario
where a certain field called the
diletton field if it changes in time in
a particular way
then the math does allow the number of
dimensions to differ
from the critical value that you make
reference to
so there are versions of string theory
that i think fit well into
an affirmative version of your question
as opposed to the negative version
that in those contexts you can have
different numbers
of dimensions uh
nervisa says i'm taking my lunch time to
listen to this
is that crazy i'll let us i'll let
others weigh in
on the state of sanity of somebody who
would waste their lunch thinking about
space time matter black holes energy the
universe why would anybody want to
spend their precious time thinking about
things
of that sort well as well you can guess
from someone who has spent a lifetime
thinking about these things
there is a reason for doing so and i
think everybody who's here
understands those reasons quite well so
enjoy your lunch
and stay with us and hopefully your
lunch break lasts long enough that you
can
stay with us for the conversation that
i'll have with howard pharma starting
about
10 or so minutes okay
the vivec asks what about warp drive
and you know there there
is i look anyone who's watched star trek
you know at least in the original
version
james t kirk talking about warp factor 5
which if i remember the conceit of the
scriptwriters warp 5 meant 5 cubed
times the speed of light and the rough
idea
if one tries to make sense of this is
that
if the speed of light truly is a speed
limit to go from here to here
if you were to go in this direction
you're never going to go there fashion
the speed of life but if you're able to
bend the fabric of space
taking that destination and bringing it
effectively
closer to your origin so that the new
journey that you take
is different shorter then you're going
to get to that destination quicker than
the speed of light
and therefore effectively you would have
traveled faster than the speed of light
even though
there would never be a moment when your
actual speed
would exceed that of light and that's
sort of the vague idea that i think the
scriptwriters
had in mind scientifically there have
been
people who have written down
mathematical versions
of warp drive i i can never i should
look it up
because now i'm embarrassed but the
there's a
you know interesting physics paper
by a physicist alcubierri
i hope i'm not saying his name
incorrectly someone can correct me in
the chat
who put some mathematics behind
the idea of a warp drive and now has a
warp drive
named after him whether you can ever
realize
this general relativity version of warp
drive in the real world is certainly an
open question but
it is at least interesting that
similar ideas to the ones that were
introduced in a completely
fantasy world science fiction world
of star trek is something that in the
physics world
people have um thought about so yes
uh has has written down the spelling of
al kubiari but i don't know if i'm
pronouncing it correctly so what i
really need is someone to give me the
phonetics
i know how it's spelled i just need the
phonetics
uh mark asks me if i did i read the book
that i sent to your secretary in the u.s
called path to life i've not mar i've
not read it mark i'm sorry i didn't even
know that it came in
and that should not be taken personally
a lot of
a lot of things come in that i just
don't have time to look at everything
but um now that you mention it i will
remember to um
ask uh ask her and uh we'll take a look
so maybe by next time i will have had a
chance to take a look
um what do we got here 12 46 let's just
do a
few more minutes before we move on to
the main
the main event um chevouch how many
dimensions
can a black hole have and that's a good
question because when
when schwarzschild wrote down the black
hole solution that i mentioned back in
1916
he was imagining three dimensions of
space in one of time
and you know for the most part that's
where a lot of the research on black
holes have taken place
but with theories of extra dimensions
like kaluza klein theory
and string theory and various super
symmetric
particle physics theories people have
written down black hole solutions in a
whole host of different dimensions
so black holes are not restricted
to three dimensions in fact in higher
dimensions people have studied all sorts
of
black objects that are called black
brains b-r-a-n-e-s
and black brains are objects
who have various numbers of extended
dimensions
but have the property that if you get
too close you can't pull away
so black holes are a very general
phenomenon they're not limited to three
dimensions of space and they're not
limited to the
form that we usually have in mind you
know this spherical event horizon around
a singularity
at the center that is a good image to
have in mind but it's not
the only image for the form that black
holes can take
oopal what is the heat death of the
universe so the heat death of the
universe
is a distant time when going back to
martin's question at the beginning where
we imagine that the low entropy starting
point of the universe
entropy has grown and grown and grown
over time
some orderly structures have formed
because of gravity as i mentioned
crushing particles together
but in the far future we do imagine that
ultimately
entropy wins out completely
and everything disintegrates into a bath
of particles that just waft through
an ever larger and ever colder universe
so it's kind of weird we call it the
heat death because
we're talking about entropy and
thermodynamics
but we aren't imagining that it's very
hot
the heat depth is very cold the heat
death is when
everything has just thermalized in the
sense that
everything comes to pretty much the same
very low temperature
uniformly throughout space and then the
idea is not
much happens from that point forward
it's not that nothing can happen and
that's an interesting
footnote to that answer and again i'm
not as you know
from these previous sessions i'm not
into advertising things here
but if you are interested in the heat
death and the various possible
fates that life and mind and the
universe
might have check out my book get it from
the library you don't have to pay for it
find a bootleg pdf copy online they do
exist
unfortunately but they do exist and uh
and you can read especially chapters um
uh 9 10 and 11 really turn from today
and take you right into the future with
the heat death being
one of the possible fates
that our universe faces all right
um does friction exist in
space shanti asks and yeah it does
not not exactly in the forum that you
have in mind i mean sure
there are say a planet moves through
space yeah it can brush up against the
microwave background radiation
in principle there's a little bit of
friction there but the friction that i
have in mind
is of a different sort it's a friction
which answers the following question you
all have gone to the science museum
when you've done that little
demonstration take a quarter or a nickel
or something you put it into a funnel
shape
trajectory and it rolls around around
and real fast and it goes right down
through the funnel
and that demonstration has led many to
ask me
about look in the general theory of
relativity the sun kind of warps the
space like the funnel
in the science museum and we always
picture the planets
sort of rolling around this funnel-like
shape why don't the planets
like a quarter or somebody from out of
the country
a coin why don't the planets like coins
spiral into the center and the answer is
planets do spiral into the center
why do they do that well the coin does
it because of friction
that's what the relevance to shanti's
question is you know there's
friction with a coin you hear it right
you hear the coin rolling so energy
being dissipated from the coin into
sound waves among other things as well
when planets are in orbit around say the
sun
they jostle the fabric of space and send
out gravitational waves gravitational
radiation not
not sound radiation but gravitational
radiation and that carries away energy
just like the sound waves carry away
energy from the coin
and so if you wait long enough a planet
like the earth will spiral into its star
if it isn't destroyed before that by
some other process
and for the sun you can calculate how
long it will take
the earth to spiral in and the answer is
about
10 to the 20 10 to the 23 years
so you know it's a long time right now
we're only 10 to the 10 years
since the big bang and we're talking
about
10 to the say 20 years before the earth
will spiral into the sun like a coin
into the funnel but
in principle it will do that and
therefore you can think of that as a
kind of friction
in space woody tells me to turn on super
chat
i don't know what super chat is is there
a thing called super chat this thing
called live chat maybe that's what i
should have had on
i had topchat on i never really know the
difference between those two
but i've now taken your suggestion woody
and i've got live
chat on for whatever it is worth um
uh akash says what do you think about
zeno's paradox
and asks that question with more
question marks than anyone
has previously used and therefore you
win the award akash kumar
for the greatest number of question
marks what do i think about zeno's
paradox
it's a nice paradox
how do you solve this paradox well it's
not that hard to solve this paradox you
see
xeno is saying that motion should be
impossible right because for
my hand to go from here to the camera it
has to go halfway
and then it has to go half of the
remaining distance and half of that and
so forth
and it seems like there are an infinite
number of steps and therefore
i will never be able to make it but of
course the error in zeno's reasoning
is to not take into account
that the smaller the step the less time
it requires for me to take that step
and indeed if you take into account that
as the distance goes
the remaining distance goes to zero the
remaining time to cover that distance
goes to zero
and use a little logic or a little
calculus you realize that of course we
can cover
a finite distance in a finite time so
the era is the implicit assumption that
every single step
will take an amount of time such that
when you add up all of the increments it
will be infinite
no an infinite number of numbers need
not add up to an
infinite value you all know that right
a half plus a quarter plus an eighth
plus a 16 plus a 30
it all adds up to one doesn't add up to
infinity
and therefore even though are there an
infinite number of steps because each
step takes an
infinitesimal duration of time
when you add up all those infinitesimals
you can get a finite answer and motion
is possible so that is
the end of zeno's paradox okay
so with that let me just take a drink of
water here
all right one more now everyone's using
a lot of question marks perhaps i
shouldn't have said that vince
and now i'm sort of rewarding
question marks a little bit foolish of
me why haven't we found the graviton
what would change if we could
prove that it exists vince asks
and first of all what is the graviton
for those of you who may not be familiar
with the term the graviton
is meant to be the smallest packet of
gravity
the messenger so to speak of the
gravitational force
the photon is the smallest packet of the
electromagnetic force the photon
is the messenger of the electromagnetic
force
and so the graviton is to gravity what
the photon
is to electromagnetism why have we never
found the graviton we have found the
photon
completely understandable gravity
is fantastically weak so much weaker
than the electromagnetic force i love
demonstrating this fact experimentally
it's the only experiment that i
as a theorist have complete confidence
that i can carry out here's the
experiment are you watching
please watch that's it i just
proved that the electromagnetic force is
much more powerful than the
gravitational force y
all of earth's gravity is pulling on
this piece
of orange rubber here okay all of
earth's gravity earth is big
my little puny muscle over here i'm not
a strong guy
my little puny muscle just beat out
the entire pull of earth gravity my
muscle is using nothing but the
electromagnetic force
and the reason my muscle can do that is
because the electromagnetic force is
much more powerful in the gravitational
force
it's you know depending how you measure
these things but it's roughly
a billion billion billion billion times
stronger
than the gravitational force
so if you're looking for the smallest
packet the graviton the smallest packet
of the weakest
force man that's a challenge
that's an incredible challenge to find
the smallest packet of the weakest
force so am i surprised that we haven't
found the graviton no in fact there are
some who suggest that
maybe there's a sense in which we will
never literally
find a graviton and yet it might still
exist
it might just be always so
washed out by other influences
in the world i don't think that's i
think we'll probably one day where one
day might mean ten thousand years from
now
have experimental evidence for the
graviton and the way that we have
experimental evidence for the photon but
that's the answer
vince to why we have never found
the graviton all right guys so thanks
for all of those questions and you
continue
you can continue to ask them as we now
turn to the next part
of the discussion here and
you know this is a little bit of a
different discussion than some of the
previous ones that we've had but in many
ways
it's the most important discussion that
we've ever had
in this series of
your daily equation or world science you
interviews or whatever you want to call
it because this is a discussion that
you know doesn't just tickle the mind
this is the one
that is relevant to our very existence
so i'd like to now
introduce dr howard varmus
who's currently a professor at weill
cornell
medicine he won the nobel prize in 1989
for his work in cancer research and is
head of the national institutes of
health
the national cancer institute and the
memorial sloan kettering cancer center
in new york city
prior to his nomination to the nih dr
varmas had been a member of the ucsf
faculty for over 20 years and received
degrees
in english literature we'll talk about
that and medicine from amherst college
harvard university and columbia
university he has long been a voice
at the intersection of politics and
science and with that i'd like to
welcome harold to our discussion hey
harold how are you doing
how are you brian thank you very much
for having me i'm very good thank you
where are you uh
well usually i'm up in columbia county
new york not too far from
your place in cairo um and uh
right now i'm in my apartment in new
york but heading up north uh
as soon as we're done yeah i mean how
how we've been in new york now and then
sometimes it's uncomfortable as i'm
dodging people in the street who aren't
wearing masks
most people are wearing masks up here
and it's it seems it's it's opening back
up
we're dining out we're going to museums
that are much less crowded than usual
yeah actually my pleasure to be up
against your
favorite pieces of art without a
thousand people crowded around you
whether they're infected or not
right the silver lining of it all so
when you when you've eaten out
have you eaten indoors or only outdoors
only outdoors so far
the weather's been nice and uh it's very
pleasant to be outside for the most part
yeah so i'd like to turn to the pandemic
in just a moment before we get there i
thought it'd be
well i would find it interesting if
you're willing to spend a little bit of
time talking about
your own background which is of course
rich
and unusual in in a wonderful way
so as i mentioned in the uh introduction
just a moment ago you majored in
in english in college you know many
people
who go on to have illustrious careers in
science to win the nobel prize in
science where
kids like me who did science fairs you
know the math
team you know all that sort of stuff so
so that wasn't your upbringing right you
wouldn't i grew up with a father who
practiced uh
family medicine and i thought i was
destined to be a doctor someday but
um i was interested in reading and
politics and
other things sports um and i went up to
college and found myself even more
diversified interested in
philosophy briefly in physics until i
found out how hard it really was
and then i went off to graduate school
literature after writing a thesis
about the novels of charles dickens and
while i was a medic while i was at
graduate school i
had an epiphany thinking that
you know if i went in to medicine and
didn't
turn up for an appointment
patients would be actually disappointed
if i was a teacher and didn't turn up
for class students might be
happy to go home and i also felt that
the part of my brain that did have some
aptitude for science was atrophying
whereas
i thought i could manage to continue to
be a thoughtful reader
and an engaged reader at a time when i
was doing science
doing science or medicine so went off
the medical school
at an interesting time when molecular
biology really
hadn't yet begin to permeate the
thinking about disease
but i was seeing clues that we were
going to understand
genes and begin to understand
disease at a much more fundamental level
i got exposed to some people who were
doing such work and working at
studying at columbia college of
physicians and surgeons where i
began to see that we were going to learn
that a disease like
sickle cell anemia was going to be
understood as a
mutation that the result of mutations
affect
very few genes and yielding prospects
for
thinking about diagnosis and prevention
and therapy in ways that were really
unprecedented
yeah and i chose the right area to go to
get into to
to work on this problem namely cancer
which is a disease of the genome and
emoji has had huge effects already so i
want to talk about that in a minute but
there's one
there's one thing i read that you
you wrote that it was actually in an
interview i believe in a 2012 journal of
clinical investigation
if you don't mind i just want to read it
because it's a really wonderful and
unusual
way of getting into
a scientific frame of mind you in
speaking about columbia medical school
you said i went there thinking that
somebody who liked words and books
was interested in the workings of mine
would be a psychiatrist but then i
became interested in internal medicine
because of its
narrative aspects can you flush that out
when you're sure well you know first of
all i i still
think that uh somebody who had a who has
more patience
with individual um ill individuals
uh would uh be attracted to
to psychiatry with uh under some
circumstances but i
when i first found myself in a room
alone with a patient
who undoubtedly had an interesting story
but whose mind was too chaotic to be
able to relate it
i realized that i really wasn't built
for that kind of thing but but when you
went to talk to a patient
who had uh a disorder of the heart
along with the kidneys they were able to
tell a narrative that
um that allowed the astute physician
which i wasn't necessarily at that point
to try to unravel
a story and make sense of it and think
about
the relationship of the patient's
experience to the physiology of disease
and then i think as at a later level
even though i never ended up practicing
medicine the ability to relate that
story to something that was happening
at a molecular and genetic level that
individual
gave rise to new ideas about how one
might do a better job in trying to
repair the defects or
coming up with public health measures
that would reduce the incidence of
disease
yeah so 1989 you win the nobel prize
for the insights that you were briefly
referring to insights
into cancer it's relationship to viruses
we had a conversation just a couple of
weeks ago with
adam reese another nobel laureate in
physics
and one thing i asked adam was i said
look you know
you won the nobel prize at that point
you've kind of reached the pinnacle in
some sense
of your field did you think about
doing something else at that point adam
was like no it's like i do fit
i do astronomy that's the only thing for
you though
am i wrong in saying that winning the
nobel prize was a turning point
of of a sort is that accurate i think
i think it is accurate not because um of
some
change internal to me but because
of the pers the world's perception of me
up until then
you know i was a i was successful i
can't deny that but
but uh i was you know a scientist
scientist people
who were interested in the molecular
biology of cancer were interested in
what i did
but i wasn't in any sense a public
figure but the prize did change
the way the world viewed me and the way
the government viewed me
i was called upon in part because i was
a nobel laureate and
because i had had some experience with
the nih to begin to advise the nih about
how it was organizing policy and
helping to to support
career development and other things and
once i got engaged in that process not
only did i find it
interesting once i was
presented with the opportunity to help
craft policy but
people who were working with me decided
that maybe i would be a good person to
help
lead the organization and then when that
that uh
offer came at a quite a high level
asking up from
from the president to be at to be
offered the
directorship of the nih uh frankly i
i jumped at it i was in a good
position because uh donna shalala my
boss at
the department of health and human
services and clinton himself were
amenable to the idea that uh i could
continue my research career at some
lower pace so i didn't have to give up
research which many people
do at that stage so i've actually
maintained a laboratory to this day
as i enter my 80s wow so i you know i do
laboratory work not with my own
hands but with through the hands of
post-docs and students and technicians
but i'm engaged in research and i've
despite
the the litany of leadership positions
that i've held over
the last 30 years or so i've been able
to keep an active interest in science
which i'm
which i'm quite grateful right now let
me uh if you don't mind i would like to
turn
to the elephant in the room if you will
the pandemic yeah
and i just want to say you know i you
know back it must have been 20
years ago i was at a talk at the new
york academy of sciences
and there is um lori garrett i believe
is the journalist's name
yes talking about the
ability of of of of tragedy hitting us
with some sort of viral
pandemic and i left that that lecture
kind of terrorized and of course
an hour two three i thought about it and
then it dissipated away and i stopped
thinking about it right and then i there
was a world science festival program
where you and i believe laurie was also
in that program
maybe others in it as well and again it
came back to mind this possibility
of and so the point i'm making is you
and others new this was
potentially coming and and yet
it's it's happened now and it's clear
that we really weren't
prepared so so is it that we weren't
prepared or were we prepared and we
botched the response
what's your view you know from 30 000
feet of why we find ourselves in this
predicament yeah well your description
of your own reaction
is actually emblematic of the way
society responds to pandemics
especially at a time when we think
science is very powerful and we're not
really threatened by the kinds of
of plagues and uh and outbreaks that
have uh
been recorded uh during history from the
time of the
14th century plagues in italy to to the
influenza epidemic of 1918.
and indeed there is a story to be told
here about
what happened after the influenza
epidemic of
of 2008 and 9. at that time
i was a member of obama's
council on scientific advisors science
and technology advisors
and we wrote a couple of
fairly stern reports about how the
nation
not only needs to up its game to deal
with
the the influenza epidemics of
that period the first year or so of the
obama administration but also
uh to prepare for the next one and one
of the things that has happened during
the current pandemic is that
about half of the old obama p cast as we
call that group
uh got together um and we've been
talking about
um what we should be doing in during
combat 19
and how we try to prepare the the
country and the world
for what will inevitably be the next one
you know
in between the flu epidemic of 2008 and
9
and current time we've had a number of
other significant outbreaks they haven't
endangered all of the world the same
level sars and mers and
ebola and zika but it tells you that
because people travel rapidly because
the the interaction of humans and
animals is still a very intimate one and
because
viruses in particular do have the
ability to spill over
from uh infected animals into human
populations
and spread uh word we're going to have
more epidemics
and there's no doubt about it and the
question is whether this
one with this tremendous severity and
the incredible attention that everyone's
given to it
will actually sustain an interest in
doing the things we know
we should do and could do to be better
prepared
we were somewhat prepared for this but
right mostly
the disaster is just the consequence of
botched oversight
right so and you have been quite
forthright and critical about certain
aspects
of the response i just want to read from
your own new york times
op-ed a particularly telling description
you wrote that the cdc the federal
agency that
should be crushing the pandemic is
promoting policies that prolong it
that means that local state and
organizational leaders will have to do
what the federal
government won't now that's pretty i
mean from someone
who's been in the positions that you
have held
that is a that is a pretty telling
description of what's going on so
what's the source of this i mean those
of us on the outside
conjecture what's going on here but
what's your view
how could the how could an organization
that was the premier disease focused
organization
on the world stage have gotten to a
place where someone in your position is
basically telling people
ignore them they're doing the wrong
thing how cool well
it's painful to say that because the cdc
indeed
is you know one of the world's if not
the most uh
prestigious organization one of the most
and uh
it's painful to say that it's it's
advising the wrong thing
to happily our
op-ed and many other statements by other
public health
public health engaged people have led to
a reversal of that policy but what they
were saying was basically we don't need
to test asymptomatic people which is
you know idiotic in the in this in this
context where we have
a pandemic caused by a virus that that
becomes highly transmissible before it
produces symptoms people don't know
they're sick
and you know we're seeing that on a big
stage uh in the last couple of weeks
when people who are
in the news anyway every day are being
prepared before the public as people who
say they have no symptoms they're fine
but of course they're producing virus
and they're
at risk of transmitting that virus
especially if they don't wear a mask
don't respect
social distancing and uh i don't know
how often they wash their hands but
the fact is that that the virus is being
transmitted
in a terrible way uh when we we know
what to do
uh you know obviously if we could uh if
we had a vaccine to put into effect if
we had
uh drugs that really protected people
against viral infection
uh i think this is the place actually
there's there is a
teachable moment here that goes well
beyond uh thinking about
this coronavirus and that is related to
the nobel prize that was announced
on on monday to investigators who
played an important role in discovering
the cause of
we call hepatitis c infection
and allowing for the development of
diagnostics in the late
1980s and a few years ago
therapeutics to prevent death from
hepatitis c
people often don't realize that we
knew about viral infections for 100
years before there were
reasonable therapies and now molecular
biology and
new kinds of drug development have
allowed the development
of drugs like the hepatitis c drug drugs
against hiv
that do an unprecedented thing they they
allow us to combat a viral infection
i'd like to see that happen in the case
of carbon 19 as well
now tony fauci as i understand it is is
a friend of yours you
and you're one of my closest friends
well so i so i i in no way i'm asking
you to
be critical but i do have a following
question if you're willing to address it
early on were there any moments when
the response that he was giving when the
administration was saying
nutty things did you ever
in your living room watching him on tv
say come on tony
really push back we gotta push back
harder
than ever well i i i i guess i respect
tony too much to
say that i was being critical but you
know i was aware that he was under
a lot of tension and my assumption was
that
he was saying what he thought was
reasonable to say in the inner sanctum
uh without publicly antagonizing the
people he needed to reach
if he was going to make any headway and
i think he's been a pretty good
purveyor of what needs to be said to the
public
um you know in the very beginning of
this pandemic we
didn't know a whole lot about this virus
we know exactly how it's being spread
there was concern for example about
how we should best deploy the the masks
that we had there was no doubt that the
the stockpile was somewhat depleted of
some of the most important
personal protective equipment that we
needed to
keep our healthcare workers maximally
safe
so there was a period in which really
had to be established that this virus
was being
transmitted largely by the aerosol route
and figure out the best way to transmit
it and to up the
the supply of the kinds of materials
like mass that can be used to protect
people yeah now look
i i think we all can agree i think that
we know how to end this pandemic we
could end it in a few weeks
right there there's this interesting
way of thinking about this problem if
everybody stayed away from everybody
else for two weeks that's it wrong right
right
virus is not trying to kill anybody the
virus is trying to survive
and only survive if it finds a new host
right but
nobody's gonna go along with that even
for two weeks we're not gonna be
completely yeah
so what do you do you know if you had a
vaccine so everybody was immunized
immunized
that's the other way to solve it we
don't have that if you had a good drug
so that nobody got seriously ill that
would help
then you could get infected and still
survive but but
so we're trying to find the right
compromise and this brings us back to
the point about asymptomatic people so
if we can identify
everybody by testing everybody every day
that itself being
somewhat implausible but if we could do
that and everybody
knew within a day of their becoming
infected or
being infectious that they were in an
infectious state then we could say
all right you stay apart from everybody
else for a couple of weeks
that's a small partial portion of the
population yeah so
in our heads we can fear how to do this
but but putting it into practical terms
yeah you know i mean i have to say part
of me feels like and of course you're
right this is completely
unrealistic but if people would just
fully embrace the fact
that in two weeks this could be over if
we just
have a certain radical change in
behavior of course that's just not
how most people think about things
that's what i said now that and that
i'll bet you quoted from that's what i
wrote
peace in the atlantic a few months
earlier in which we said i have the
atlantic here
yeah so is is that an unrealistic hope
to ever get the public into the frame of
mind where
okay a new pandemic is spreading across
the world here's what we need to do and
everybody just
isolates for two weeks and it's very
difficult but i do think that
it is possible to get people in the
frame of mind understand that if they
get
tested anybody who you've got to
prioritize too because you can't
just produce 300 million tests a day and
execute them and
get the get the sample to the lab and
the results back to people and
and do the follow-up testing but if you
can say
this cohort of individuals needs to be
tested because they
they're going into a situation where
they're at risk
these people need to be tested because
they're likely to transmit
the virus in a certain in a certain
circumstance you test
that 5 or 15 that's at the
greatest risk of continuing the
transmission the virus then you can get
control of it maybe it's not
perfect but uh all we have to do is get
the the transmission rate down to a
an acceptably low level and then the
virus goes away maybe it doesn't go away
in two weeks maybe it's six weeks
but look it's been seven months more
than that actually but
yep exactly now i have the atlantic
article and there is one
one quote that i wanted to just quickly
read that you wrote
you wrote that we believe that expanding
current testing capacity remains a
matter of extreme urgency one that
justifies a level of intense coordinated
work
at a national even international scale
that resembles the campaigns
we associate with world wars very
powerful way of describing the need for
the kind of testing that you were just
mentioning now however in contrast with
that right
president trump at times he's been
advocating slowing down
testing and we already discussed how the
cdc had been suggesting
curtailing the kind of testing that
we're doing and
i don't know did you watch the debate
last night the vice presidential debate
a little bit yeah so
here you've got vice president pence
castigating kamala harris
saying that she was politicizing
vaccines bring politics into a domain
that that really affects
people's lives it's the
it's the epitome of hypocrisy here
you've got
these particular political goals
influencing the most vital way that we
can deal
with this pandemic i mean well i think
he was pretending to miss the point
about um
being cautious about a recommendation
that comes not from the fda
not from tony noche not from the
scientific community
but only from frankly a
disorganized disoriented leader who has
in the past told us that we should uh be
taking drugs that have not been
validated who himself once he got sick
uh took every possible therapy
including things that if he weren't
particularly ill he shouldn't be taking
like dexamethasone
and what do we do i mean because the
fact of the matter is
the various polls have shown that
something like only one in five
people would take the vaccine if it were
say
available today that low but that uh but
i've seen
hundreds under 400 i saw the number 21
of pulse i don't know how accurate it is
to ask the question who you ask but yeah
of course no doubt but i guess my
question is
i don't know a lot about the details
that you are
intimately familiar with regarding the
kinds of
protocols that are generally in place to
assure that a vaccine is safe so when i
hear
the president talking about operation
warp speed and rushing things and
getting a vaccine before the election
if you were to ask me would i take that
vaccine if it was available today
you know kamala harris had a funny
remark she said you know if trump says
it's okay i won't take it but if the
doctors tell me it's okay i will
i sort of have a similar frame of mind
but what does the general person do
how do you know in the context of a
country that now
is trying to circumvent the usual
protocols in order to rush a vaccine how
do you know if it's safe to take
yeah well i i i have some residual faith
that we're going to be
told at least something about how
effective
uh any vaccine is in a clinical trial
all the vaccines that are being
considered for approval
are in phase 3 trials and i think there
are enough people who are concerned
about
transparency in this process even if
they're not in government
and will have access to the data to
reveal uh
what the the consequences of taking the
vaccine
actually are i do think that that side
effects are going to be
infrequent i don't think i think we have
a hard time knowing exactly how
infrequent
um but i think we will know but have to
know understand how to respond to is how
effective it is
yeah fda has quite reasonably said that
the vaccine has to be at least 50
effective with respect to either
blockage of infection
or the development of serious uh illness
after you're infected
uh and i think people have to begin to
understand that
a decision about a vaccine is not a
binary decision it's not we have a
vaccine that we don't
we could have a vaccine that's pretty
good worth approving
worth using but we have to retain
other kinds of precautions to try to
reduce transmission because
some vaccines may not be perfect
nevertheless sufficiently
useful to to use and i think we have to
mainta if we if that
becomes the case and it is true that we
have vaccines against some diseases
dengue fever malaria that have gotten
approvals
when they're not all that effective but
they're helpful
and once that is the case people have to
understand that
we want to encourage people to make
better vaccines
we want people who take the vaccine to
be
first of all alert to the possibility of
of adverse events when you take them
it's hard you know just so you're
responsive to changes and symptoms
and you've got to be sure those folks
understand they still have to take some
precautions they
still should be aware they could get
infected
and if they're infected they can
transmit the virus uh so
i think you know for the next year two
three possibly people are gonna have to
be adaptable enough to say
these precautions we put in place and
you know here in new york city
i would say most people are wearing
masks most people are distancing
we're behaving pretty well like ninety
percent i would say i'd say ten percent
uh raucous youth in the village it's
different than if you're in the sedate
upper
uh aging upper west side
yeah no no certainly that uh has has an
impact um let me ask you
so we learned this disturbing
fact from uh the
bob woodward book about the trump
administration knowing
certain features about the virus and
holding it back
that certainly played a role in the
debate last night when it comes to
transparency
how do you make a decision about what
information to share
with the public and what information
should somehow be kept
under wraps do you have a a guiding
principle
for what to do with that kind of
sensitive information
yeah i mean i i don't think it's a
huge problem but i do think people have
to understand
that that in under conditions like the
pandemic
the natural tendency for most scientists
who have new information is to try to
share it quickly
and one of the one of the delicacies
about or delicate situations that has
arisen
here is that scientists especially
under these conditions are more and more
likely to divulge information
at a pretty early stage before they
actually have
what we would call solid
solid data to support a
conclusion and we do i think all of us
have been aware
of conclusions that have been
proposed uh results that have been
posted
before uh conventional peer review that
turned out not to be correct and science
is a self
largely a self-correcting enterprise in
physics or biology
uh and the mistakes do occur and here
the the stakes are high because we're
talking about
the pandemic and people's health is at
stake
and you have to achieve a balance which
i think
varies very hard to write down as a
series of principles
between being
transparent about about early results
and convincing people that you're not
you know that uh you're divulging
information but you're not
yet secure about the conclusions people
have a hard time accepting they think
science
knows things and when you're a science
supporter you think if a scientist says
it and writes it down and puts it into
even into
online as part of a preprint server as
you would in
archive for example and we do in bio
archive
um then you know this is somehow
now written in stone which it's not yeah
yeah i know i find
also you know people have the
view that science is all about one
revolution after another
overturning everything that came before
and i try to emphasize to people that
science is
generally about just expanding the
domain that you can talk about
with precision and typically the ideas
of the past are not
overturned they're simply extended so i
do think that we have a bit of a
mismatch
between how science actually works and i
mean not
people who are audience for this
discussion typically but for the general
person it's a
it's a pretty different view compared to
how science actually
does work and but the issue that you
raise
does bring to mind the question look
pandemic is obviously something that
doesn't care about borders
science is a field the beauty of it is
that it doesn't care about borders
you know and we work on something and we
look at the pre-print server that you
just mentioned
the pre-prints come from all over the
world every morning there's new work
coming in
so it's vital that there's international
cooperation and trying to combat
something
of this sort how has america's response
and america's leadership in this
pandemic
affected our international rep
reputation among the very scientists
that we need to work with to to really
stamp this out yeah that's an incredibly
important question brian i've been
mulling a lot about that because
one of the reasons people are so
perturbed by
the terrible performance of our of our
country
in this epidemic that that is we have uh
four percent of the world's population
but
uh over 20 percent of of covered 19
deaths how could that possibly happen
and i i don't think yet we've eroded our
reputation
for doing important science indeed most
of the things that have allowed us to
identify the pathogen characterize it
develop
interesting tests uh produce
vaccine candidates at unprecedented
speed
using not just virus that's been killed
or virus that's been
attenuated in its potency but by using
viral nucleic acid and viral proteins
and having a pretty sophisticated view
of how this virus
enters cells and grows some of that
based on
antique work or 20 year old work with
coronaviruses but some of it based on
incredibly rapid advances that have been
made through the technological tools
that
that only we in a few other places in
the world
mean in europe and some places some in
china uh
i think that's all still viewed as
remarkable and that
the botched performance here has a lot
to do with american attitudes toward
public health something we want to talk
about a little bit more detail
and uh the the the incredible
mishaps that have occurred because of mr
trump and his colleagues yeah
yeah it's uh it's sort of astounding i
mean as as
someone who has had high level
government posts under president clinton
under president obama i mean we all know
that
politics always casts some kind of
shadow over science these are not
independent realms but have
you ever encountered the kind of
influence and the
kind of meddling and the kind of
manipulation
that is going on with this
administration absolutely not
yeah you know you know i haven't been in
the republican administration but i've
watched you know george bush and we
were very critical of george w bush um
not so much his father but uh um but in
fact uh
george w bush looks like a scientific
messiah
by by comparison you know he ran the
pepfar program
um developed it on his own uh and that
was one of the great public health
efforts in history of man um and
uh you know he did have some bizarre
policies with respect to stem cell
research and a few other things but
uh he was in general supportive of
the kind of research done across the
board and
looks like a rational human being which
i think he is
right right which uh now is the low bar
for uh respect for
before we have a little more respect for
the biden harris ticket than that i
think
yeah so that would be a big improvement
so you know
i mean trump fed off and feeds off
a certain view at least in america
among a certain fraction of the populist
that distrusts
expertise that puts dogma in front
of evidence and approaches the world
in a highly non-scientific
way and so i'm often asked the question
you know what do we do about science
literacy
or illiteracy in america and i kind of
tell you i've got sort of two views on
this because
on the one hand as you know this is a
world science festival event we run this
festival and hundreds of thousands of
people out to the events
millions of people watch the online
programs that that we post which is
which is great so there is a hunger and
an interest
in these ideas so it's not universal
that there's no interest in science and
then the flip side and i know that
you've written about this too and i'll
just give my version of it
you know i know a little bit about genes
i know
a little bit about dna but
i don't know anywhere near what you know
and so you could call me illiterate in
certain
areas of science because it's just too
deep for any one individual to be
everything which is for instance when
people ask me about climate change
i am reluctant to get into a deep
conversation about i'm not a denier by
any means but
i know that a really smart denier could
probably wipe the floor with me because
if they've done their work
and their research they may know details
that i won't
simply be able to respond to
how do we deal with this puzzle
if you will is there a certain body of
science that you think
every single person should at least know
that or is it more that we just have to
inculcate
a sort of scientific mindset that
allows people to recognize that there's
a rational way of looking at the world
and there's an irrational way i mean
what do we do
i think this is an incredibly important
issue and i i struggle all the time with
colleagues of mine who say you know
we're living in a scientifically
illiterate society well you know
scientific literacy
is uh you know is hard to define and
whatever
my colleagues who work in molecular
biology might think is an illiterate
uh state of mind actually could be
pretty literate so
i give a course as you may know in the
mcauley honors college at the city
university of new york on science and
society where we try to take up this
issue
and my view is if you can teach people
to learn some of the principles that go
go into how
science is done to learn what the
liabilities of scientific
exploration are how science is funded
how science is
is disseminated how we get access to
information
how it's taught what uh
what forces economic ethical and other
otherwise are influencing how scientists
make decisions
what scientific truth is because uh
as you know from thinking about the
philosophy of science
uh it's hard to prove something and
people can learn these principles of
what
a rational exploration of the world is
all about and what
experimental evidence tells us and how
interpretations change
uh that there are imperfections there's
fraud there are all kinds of things
that uh undermine the credibility of
science and if we learn that
science is a human activity that that
we have to defend ourselves uh to
uh avoid um perpetuating as though
any scientific paper is written in stone
yeah when we
we've taught people about uh how the
scientific profession
operates what its pushes and pulls are
and
i think that's the best we can do and
then there you know i would say there
are some things we ought to know a
little bit about you were illustrating
gravity a moment ago people
have some sense of where that concept
came from what it means
what the major forces are and you know i
would say likewise that
it's really a mark of of
of poor education not to know something
about
what genes are how they're encoded what
they do
um you don't have to know a lot of a lot
of individual genes you have to remember
remember the base pairs
the sequence of base pairs in your dna
but you do you want to know
something about the general principles
involved and
that's where we have to depend on our
educational
apparatus which is uh somewhat deficient
in this country especially
uh below the university level
um what would you be in favor like of a
surprise question in one of these
presidential debates
where you know trump or biden has asked
you know what what is a gene what is dna
i think it would be great but that would
it would
raise the level of this discourse quite
a lot and of course the answer might be
something about something totally
irrelevant just as last night
some of the most interesting questions
which was totally ignored people
pulled up their two minutes and more was
i don't understand
why a failure to answer the question or
to try to answer the question
to say i'm not going to answer that
question but i'm going to say
this because i need to say this right
right
yeah now uh that that's uh the the
dynamics of its own little universe of
uh
political science what is that science
yeah right exactly but speaking of which
so there are many
scientists who would not go on the
journey
that you have in your life there are
some scientists
and i'm around many of them and i used
to think this way myself
we are about discovering truth right
transcendent truths that are so
beyond these little noisy things about
policy and life on planet earth and
we're not going to spend our time in
that domain
so so the question is should we in the
educational system
have some encouragement that
allows scientists to know that it is
important to go on the journey that
you've gone on the variations on that
theme
that others have gone on too should in
graduate school
should there be courses like perhaps the
one that you're teaching
where policy and and the politics of
science and the politics of funding is
part of the
the training because i can assure you
that in graduate school and physics
that's like
infinitely far away you're learning
quantum field theory quantum gravity
as best you can the electrodynamics and
none of that other stuff matters
yeah well my view is that yes people
should have an opportunity to
learn about these things if they so
choose i some of my
colleagues feel it should be mandatory
and i take a
somewhat dim view of that i think i have
i'm perfectly happy to know that a
certain percentage of my colleagues
just want to do their science they don't
want to get engaged in politics i
i see this frequently especially in this
election year with the pandemic and all
the other things
revolving around us uh when nobel
laureates for example are
approached about signing a letter uh
that either
takes a position on the election or
condemns the current administration for
something
and i find about three quarters of maybe
eighty percent of
of laureates are willing to pitch in and
make a statement i
this time when we put together a letter
in support of
vice president biden uh over 80 of the
new laureates of the nobel laureates in
america
were willing to sign on to a letter
which is a record and i think not
surprising because
you can't ignore the fact that the
survival
of the scientific enterprise is closely
linked to politics and
the most primitive level we know that
most science in america is paid for with
federal dollars so
yeah that's a requirement to have a
congress that is
receptive towards scientific work and uh
but i think at a time when the
findings of science that are essential
to the survival of
our citizens is being abused um
most scientists i know except for you
know there are a few who are simply
too old to think about what the letter
says or have taken a principle position
that
they're scientists they don't know
enough about things and you know i draw
that line too i
get approached about uh signing on to
some political
uh event in a country i know very little
about and
uh i'm hesitant to sign something of
that sort but
i do think that you know first of all we
are citizens
as well as being scientists and if we
have influence
perhaps we should use it when we care
about the issue and secondly we can't
we can't ignore the fact that that
society
is intimately linked through its
politics it's governance
uh to the scientific enterprise and we'd
be foolish i think
to ignore those connections yeah i know
we experienced the same kind of thing
you may recall years ago when we were
just starting the world science festival
we approached you tracy day and i
approached you would you be an advisor
on and you graciously said yes which we
greatly appreciated
but we had been told that there were
going to be very few nobel laureates
that were willing to sign on for much
the reason
that you're you're saying that you know
signs for the public
taking a political position
exactly it was just the public about
these ideas
and but it turned out that not a single
nobel laureate that we approached turned
us down
so so there i felt there was a nice
shift toward the recognition of how
important it is for the public to know
about these people
you may take up controversial topics
right i wouldn't say
we've got a position the science fair is
a controversial thing
exactly exactly precisely right did you
experience
any pushback from your colleagues when
you first started to
at least spend part of your time outside
of the
traditional academic world i don't think
so because frankly
i think most of my colleagues feel that
there's a risk to having people who
are no longer doing science or may not
have been strong scientifically
helping to run the the agencies that
give out the federal dollars
so you know my i've never spent
too much time in some of the
more garden variety things that deal
with
issues that help microbiologists to
survive for example so
my interest has always been federal
agencies and how
the government works how congress comes
to support science how it provides
oversight
and i think most of my colleagues are
just concerned about having people
who have a reasonable point of view and
i guess i can take it as a
mark of commendation that people didn't
object to my doing on the ground so i
wouldn't be any good at it
so i've never had much problem with that
but you know i have
occasionally when we weigh in on things
like the recent
kerfuffle about the rescinding of a
grant
to an organization in new york that was
right about that yeah
how viruses transmitted from bats to
humans
in china in particular and that grant
was
was uh in a sense withdrawn money is
no is not money for that grant doesn't
go to the investigator at this point
and that's all a consequence of trump
having been asked a question
uh at a press conference uh that
he didn't know what the grant was
obviously but he felt
he was being told that the grant
provided money to the institute of
virology and wuhan
and he said we'll we're going to
discontinue that
and then word went down and that's what
happened
sort of end of story happily it hasn't
been hasn't recurred but
uh you know i don't like
calling out my esteemed colleagues and
my
own favorite agency the nih in public
but i think if
if we didn't stand up to that and make
it
and say this is not acceptable we don't
want this to happen
i think it's important that we speak our
mind and recognize that this is
not um the kind of action we want to see
our agency leaders to take
and it serves has the potential to serve
as a very unfortunate president because
there are countries in which science is
undermined
by overt political interference and we
can't allow that to happen
yeah and look november third obviously
is a pretty critical time
critical date when we're talking about
how this country is going to
go forward you know if it goes in the
trump direction it's probably going to
be business as usual which would be
catastrophic but
if biden prevails
and let's just for argument say because
it could well happen
he calls upon you to head up
the viral task force to deal with the
current pandemic
and the next one that no doubt is
heading our way
what would be your guiding principles
for what we should do to be ready for
the next time around
well let me say first of all that i
think there's no doubt
that uh and possibly even in the trump
administration there would be
a a commission called by congress
and the the group that i mentioned
earlier of
former members of obama's pcast have
actually written
a long and thoughtful essay about what
the commission
the co the kavit 19 commission should
take on
and it's clear that uh there are a
number of things to worry about one
is how we organize the underlying
science to
cope directly with making good tests and
new therapeutics and vaccines against
the next pandemic and we do know that
there are new ways to
to do certain kinds of science
especially in the infectious disease
domain
that would be even more efficient than
what's happened this time
secondly we need to be much more
conscious of being prepared
with the kinds of materials that you
stockpile and
and store up we need to think about how
testing and contact racing in particular
is done we ought to have a cohort of
people who are ready
to put in place the cohort the the
contact racing that
is essential for testing to make sense
because testing is obviously
not very valuable if we don't follow up
with
people who've been in contact with
infectious individuals
uh so there are hope there's a litany of
things that need to be done
and one of which i think is often
forgotten but fundamentally important we
i mentioned it
very briefly earlier and that is we need
to change public consciousness of what
it means
to protect the nation's health it's not
just about
curing a case of cancer or curing a
person who's got an infectious disease
we need to pay much more attention in
this country in particular
to public health as to prevention of
disease and to the understanding of
what aspects of our behaviors
contribute to disease they're countries
that are much less wealthy than we are
and you know what they are taiwan and
iceland and south korea and quite a
number of others
that have coped much more effectively
vietnam another good example
much less effectively with this much
more effectively than we have within
pandemic
because they have a public health system
that
doesn't cost all that much and maybe
less sexy to
to prevent a case of disease than it is
to cure it
but nevertheless we just need to change
our perspective the cdc
is under ordinary circumstances a very
valuable
organization it doesn't have the
resources
ever that it ought to have to to protect
the country and
you know we do depend heavily on city
and state
public health departments unfortunately
in this circumstance we have to depend
almost entirely on them and of course
the quality varies across the country
which
accounts for why uh you know as you said
before
virus doesn't respect national
boundaries or state boundaries or
urban boundaries and we need a
coordinated response
and we haven't had that we can change
the public perception
of what public health does for not a
whole lot of money
and that should be one of the underlying
themes in any commission report
so we only have a few minutes there are
two other things i wanted to talk about
each of which could fill a full
conversation
but you mentioned cancer obviously
that's
an arena where you've had a profound
impact
can you summarize just give us a sort of
state of play in your view
i mean i know that you said that
obviously curing cancer versus
preventing cancer perhaps we really
should be focusing more
on the louder than the former but where
do we stand in
in that battle yeah well let me just say
a couple of things about that
first one of the things that has really
impressed me in the last five or ten
years
is the rapid development of new
technologies that can allow us to
understand cancer in a much more
profound way
using new approaches to look
not just at the molecular gyrations in
in a cancer but in individual cells
and when you start to do that you begin
to see how
how much heterogeneity how much
variation there is within a cancer
that mutations are continually occurring
cancers are evolving and have a kind of
plasticity that makes
for an evolutionary universe that
that makes the new therapies that we're
very excited about
drugs that specifically target
individually mutated genes
new immunotherapies that that that
allow the immune system to attack cancer
cells that
that have foreign-like proteins on their
surface
these are remarkable developments
but the the ongoing plasticity the
generation of new new attributes of
cancer cells as
cancers grow and metastasize is truly
extraordinary but we now
through what we call single cell biology
have a much
better approach to understanding this
incredibly difficult problem
because we don't cure as many cancers as
i'd like
to see us cure um you know i use
prevention
as a as a concept that i think
we need to do more with in in
human populations and how effective
could that be and you're thinking about
the way
so yeah so i think you know we are
limited in
in our approaches to cancer we know that
if nobody smoked
we'd have much less lung cancer there's
no doubt about that one of the biggest
uh reducers of the incidence of cancer
in this country
and the reduction of mortality in this
country has been
through smoking cessation that's only
one example
unfortunately cancer a disease of the
genome in which
in which it's hard to prevent the damage
that occurs because some of it is
part of the natural process you know
people
cells reproduce themselves many many
times
during the course of a lifetime and
every time they do that they've got to
make
a perfect rendition of three billion
pairs of nucleotides and segregate 23
pairs of chromosomes to daughter cells
they don't do that
in a in an accurate manner and so
there's an implicit
tendency towards genetic change as
normal cells grow we now know
if you take the first two cells that are
that develop during embryogenesis when
the
fertilized egg divides into two cells
those cells already have mutations
really yeah because everything yes
right most of those mistakes don't
matter because a lot of our dna
has minimal functional penetrance
yeah what's the rate the rate is sort of
at the level of you know
a half of a percent and well no no much
less than that
but remember the number three billion
base pairs
yes a number i got the number wrong
um yeah they're right there's a lot
there's a lot of copying to make there
bible repair systems but it's not enough
you know one in 10 to the seventh
that's a lot right of course
now that we have these technologies
allow us to do something really
extraordinary take
one cell we'll let divide into two
sequence
the dna in one of those daughter cells
single cell
uh you can do that and you can find that
the mistakes are occurring all the time
and
when those mistakes change the function
of an important gene
doing damage so we're getting a handle
on some of those things
yeah i think that's going to be helpful
i mean some of that will be helpful with
regard to understanding how cancer
arises learning
having a mindset about the plasticity
the variation
of cells in a cancer uh and the cancers
are not
uh they're not monolithic they're not
uniform sets of cells they have
the potential to undergo the kinds of
evolutionary changes
due to election that's imposed by giving
a drug
so we have all these new drugs putting
these drugs together
is going to be very powerful yeah
combinations
so the one thing fails on somebody else
succeeds it's hard for a cell to escape
two obstacles to its growth rather than
one yeah it's sort of
amazing and wondrous and frightening at
both the same time that the very process
that allows
for evolution to yield the kind of
species on earth you and i wouldn't
exist brian
there weren't mistakes and speciation
exactly
if you want i'm going to do that you've
got to tolerate cancer as well
exactly exactly let me ask one final
final question with all of the
absolutely spectacular new developments
in in all of science but certainly in
medical science medical technology and
so forth that's happening
if you were right now a young medical
student just starting out
what direction do you think you would go
with the playing field as it currently
is
yeah no i you know to me the biggest
scientific problem
has to do with energy if you're thinking
about problems that affect
the future of mankind getting get
finding ways to store energy to
get more energy out of the sun for
example
uh relieving our dependence on fossil
fuels these are the things that really i
think
are going to affect the future of human
life
um if i were confining myself to medical
things
you know like many of my colleagues i
probably would be focused on
neuroscience
i actually entered medicine we talked
about that earlier
psychiatry but like freud i took an
interest in
the structure and function of the brain
but i just found it
too difficult i think it's still awfully
difficult
a lot of progress has been made in the
last 20 years
but that's you know understanding how
the brain works what consciousness is
these are
these are the problems that uh are at
the
vern being approached now genetics
cancer
infectious disease these are still
fascinating topics but i do think we
have
the basic repertoire of principles and
technologies
uh now it's a matter of working things
out and you know they're people
who differ i like to start things and
the starting
genetic exploration of what drives
cancer was
part of my contribution to science
what's going on now is fun it's
interesting that
you know i work for example on forms of
lung cancer that are still very
difficult to treat
that's an exciting thing but i don't
feel as though
we're at um at a frontier in which we're
going over a fence that's too hard to
see over i think we
have some sense of what the landscape is
like it's just a matter of
working out incredibly important aspects
of these phenomena that will allow us to
to treat maybe even prevent some of
these diseases more effectively but
i think in the in the neurosciences in
particular
they're going to be fundamental
discoveries and let me just
conclude on one thing the other nobel
prize in my field that occurred this
week was the prize for crispr
yes um which is a you know a
resonating
reaffirmation of the importance of basic
science
we now can all envision using the crispr
editing systems to treat
prevent cure human disease but
this would never have happened that
people have not been obsessively looking
at the
at the chromosomes of bacteria and
trying to understand how they become
resistant to infection by
bacterial viruses and that began in the
1980s
this nobel prize went to two people out
of about 20 or 30 who were
prominent in the development of this
story i'm really pleased it went to two
women that's great
um and i think it's it's it's an
opportunity
for um for storytellers to say yes these
people
did something that was pivotal in the
history of this field
but there were it was the graduate
student who was just looking at
organisms that
swim around in very salty water uh and
who saw these strange sequences and
people who began to apply the principles
of crispr
to the editing of dna in in human cells
that
you know represent a full the full glory
of science from
fundamental stuff to things that are
highly applied and
are going to be useful in agriculture
and archaeology and many other areas of
human exploration so i said that was the
final question but do you mind me asking
one more since it came
up so you mentioned neuroscience
the brain consciousness as you know a
frontier that
at some point will be able to explore
in some systematic scientific way
what's your your gut feeling is
consciousness something that
we will understand by virtue of deeply
understanding
neural processes or as some say
it will it forever be beyond the reach
of that kind of a mechanistic
description yeah i think we're going to
be able to say
that consciousness is reflected in
certain can be linked to certain um
physical attributes uh whether it's uh
the configuration of rna or movement of
electrons through
some kind of molecular cycle
but i think it's still going to be hard
to connect the experience of
having a consciousness to those
molecular events
and i'm that i think remains to be seen
let's let's let's try to figure out
a way to understand what the objective
correlates of consciousness are
yeah and then see if we can link it back
and
make a theory of the whole
yeah now the hard problem of
consciousness why we have these inner
worlds is certainly
well described as a hard problem and
yeah maybe
some of the young folks listening to
this will one day contribute to that so
harold thank you so much for
joining us on this conversation you know
about science
politics the pandemic cancer
consciousness
critical issues your insights are
incredibly valuable and thank you for
sharing them with us today
my pleasure thanks for your good work
with the wsf
thank you thank you okay talk soon
all right everybody so let's uh do a
little more q a before we uh
wrap it up today uh
again that was a bit of a departure for
the kinds of topics that we usually talk
about let us know
if that's the kind of thing you'd like
us to do more of and again this one
is so vital to the future sorry for
those of you
on the international side of
the viewership that it was somewhat
america-centric
but what happens in this country has
profound ripple effect across the world
so
i suspect that many of you even if you
don't live in the united states are uh
deeply concerned with what's happening
in america which is deeply distressing
to
many of us so again we uh we thank
harold varmus for
sharing some time with us so heading
back to the kinds of things that i can
talk to
directly we do another 15 minutes or so
of
questions before we uh before we wrap it
up let's see um
[Music]
um aditya asks what is a naked
singularity and a naked singularity this
is nice because it
ties right back to our initial
conversation about black holes in the
first part
of today's session black holes according
to the math have a singularity but the
singularity
is encased it's kind of shrouded
within what we call the event horizon we
mentioned this earlier as well
and that shroud you can almost think of
it
as clothing that surrounds the
singularity a naked singularity would be
a singularity that
doesn't have an event horizon
surrounding it it doesn't have any
clothing
surrounding it therefore we call it
naked and
there's a lot of debate about whether
well as i mentioned earlier there's a
debate about singularities how best to
address them what they mean how to deal
with them
there have been questions about whether
naked singularities are
even allowed within the general theory
of relativity and there's been a lot of
work done
on that no one's ever actually seen a
naked singularity so it's not as though
it's something
that we can point to the way we can
point to black holes
which now we've actually taken radio
telescope images
of but it is a potential quality of the
general theory
of relativity nobel surfer ass what do
you think about
the ccc cosmological model advanced by
sir roger penrose
um you know i wish i had something
intelligent to say about it
i know roger has been putting forward
that idea for a while and he has a book
on i've not read his book i've not
really studied the idea
so unfortunately i i don't feel
qualified at the moment to
give any real evaluation of that but at
some point
i'll look into it more fully so if we
have if you join us again in a
subsequent time feel free to ask again
maybe i will have something
more useful to say about it um cj
enjoyed the covet 19 discussion an
excellent witness to the insightful
perspectives from dr varmus thank you i
appreciate your response to that
um uh raghav anand what is a string
made of that's a that's a good question
natural one to ask we know that
matters made of molecules molecules made
of atoms we know
atoms of course all you know are made of
protons and neutrons in the nucleus with
quarks and quantum orbits
and you've got with electrons and
quantum orbits and quarks inside the
protons and neutrons
and so with strings if string through is
correct which is big if
the next level of description would be
inside those orbiting
electrons you'd find this vibrating
filament inside those quarks
inside those protons you'd find these
little vibrating filaments
and you say okay so
sequence upon sequence we find something
smaller when we get inside of a string
is there something that it
too is made of and we don't really know
the answer
there are people who have pursued
more refined versions of a string if you
will
using things called d0 particles it's a
natural consequence of a formulation of
strings that
strings themselves might be in some
sense
a necklace of these little d0 zero means
zero dimensional as opposed to
d1 which is one dimensional string that
a string might be sort of a necklace of
these d0
particles these d0 brains but it could
be
on the other hand that a string if this
idea is correct at all
that's the big if strings might be it
they might
be a truly fundamental entity and
there might not be a notion of something
finer within them it's a kind of
unfamiliar idea
because for most everything we encounter
in the world
the idea of it being built up from
something finer
makes a lot of sense but look i mean
just by analogy
if i give you a book the book has
pages on which there are paragraphs and
the paragraphs are made of sentences
the sentences are made of words the
words are made of letters
but if i then say okay what makes up a
letter i mean sure you can talk about
the ink
on the page i guess but if i ask you
from a linguistic
standpoint like what makes up a letter
you know in written language a letter is
a fundamental ingredient should have
strokes and lines but
they don't hold any linguistic meaning
so
the final meaningful ingredient in that
linguistic reductionist germany journey
is a letter
and that's it and you know there are
many letters
in a given alphabet they're all
fundamental
so the fact that there are many of them
doesn't necessarily mean that they are
not fundamental
so that could be this same thing with
strings
strings may be the end of the line in
that progression in the sense that
there's nothing more meaningful to point
to
when your question is associated with
the
elementary ingredients of matter that
could be the end of the line again i
i can't help but stressing that we don't
know if string theory is correct it's a
mathematical theory
we don't have the experimental
verification all things that you already
know but i don't want it to
somehow go by you that it's a very
speculative
idea as of today um
what else we had um uh my ten-year-old
according to kisa
asks my ten-year-old asks why is space
dark
that's actually a very deep question uh
dakisa and your 10 year old son or
daughter
because there was a time when
a fellow named uh oblers was his name i
forget his name first name maybe
sometimes william
william oblers and he put forward
oblar's paradox which asked why is space
dark
exact same question what was alders
thinking over saying hey
if you look out into space and
if space is kind of uniformly filled
with stars
then if you look out into space your
line of sight should hit
some star even if it's far away and that
star give off
gives off light that will travel along
that
trajectory to your eye so obelisk was
saying in
every single direction your eyeball
should encounter an incoming photon
which would mean that the sky would not
be dark
the sky would be bright and this was a
puzzle that
people began to think about and
the answer speaks to the finite age
of the universe because if the universe
was
infinitely old and light could travel
infinitely far because that journey
could take as much time as it needs to
reach your eye
then yeah you should encounter photons
from every direction
in space but if the universe is a finite
age then in various directions
light simply may not have had enough
time to reach your eyeball
in the time since the big bang and that
would suggest
an explanation for why regions of the
sky would be dark
so i think the best answer to your
child's question to keith as to why is
space dark space is dark
because the universe isn't infinitely
old and not being infinitely old means
that
light has not had unlimited time to
reach us and there could be
light everywhere out there traveling
toward us
but it simply hasn't had enough time to
reach us
very good question and whatever the name
of your ten-year-old is
please tell them to keep on asking
questions
as that's what it is all about
um what else we have um
uh tony silva there's no expansion
between
particles that's true and that is a
puzzle that some people ask if the
universe is expanding
space is stretching and you've got two
particles
even two particles i don't know within
this little piece of orange
rubber that i'm holding why aren't the
particles in this material
moving apart there's space inside of
this
why is it not moving apart and the
answer
is that this is held together
by forces that we've discussed the
electromagnetic force the nuclear force
is holding it all together
and because of that force being much
stronger as i demonstrated earlier today
you know
electromagnetic force remember stronger
than the gravitational force
it can hold things together it can
withstand but that
i should note need not always be the
case so the kicker
is that if the accelerated expansion of
space that we are now witnessing
if that picks up in magnitude if the
acceleration of space
accelerates then it's conceivable that
in the far
future the expansion of space will be so
powerful that
even particles within an object will be
pushed apart by the swelling space even
the electrons in those quantum orbits
around the nucleus the space between the
electron and the nucleus
may swell driving the atom itself
to rip apart and so it's not
impossible although we do consider it
deeply
unlikely but it's not impossible that in
the far future
everything will be ripped apart by the
expansion of space that's
what's known as the big the big rip
one of the other earlier somebody asked
about the heat death
of the universe so in addition to the
heat death of the universe the universe
could die through the big rip through
everything being ripped
apart all right a few more
questions before we wrap it up for today
uh here sorry hurry
if space expanded where's the whole
space
and i understand the question we
normally
we normally think of an object expanding
into an existing container or
realm like when bread expands
when it rises it rises into
the space within the oven you know if i
have a piece of
material rubber and i stretch it it's
stretching within the ambient
environment
when we talk about space expanding
it's odd because we want to picture
space expanding within an environment
too
because our brains are so used to
thinking about expansion
in that setting something expanding
within something else
space we think may be profoundly
different
from that picture of ordinary objects
in the universe within space
space may well be the entirety of
reality
no container no external space is the
be all and end all the whole shebang
when space expands what's happening is
the fabric of space is stretching and
thereby creating new space
that the universe then inhabits it's not
as though
the space is expanding and encroaching
upon
pre-existing territory that the universe
somehow hadn't
earlier acquired no space
may be stretching and creating the new
space
and in that manner not filling
more of a pre-existing domain rather
creating a larger
domain than previously existed that's
the difference
all right uh so jacob says but professor
greene
i'm not sure what to do with but
professor greene i guess i could take
that
question anywhere but jacob if there's
another half to your question feel free
to
include it somewhere else um
spin foams do the people in the chat
know about jj sakurai
spin foams i don't know jj's sakurai of
course
a vital force in the development of
physics
quantum mechanics has a great textbook
on quantum mechanics i i don't know i'm
not exactly sure why you're asking but
uh i don't know maybe uh
saad raza if the universe is 13 billion
years old then how can we see
92 billion light years away
yeah it's a that's a sounds puzzling at
first
if the universe is 13 billion years old
right then you'd think that from any
given direction at most you could see is
13 billion light years in every
direction because as i said before you
can only
see in directions where light has had
enough time to reach you
right i shouldn't say seeing directions
you only see at
distances from which it's a better
saying it you can only see distances
from which light has had enough time
to reach you farther away they wouldn't
so what do we mean
and i often say this too when we don't
actually say that the universe's
radius is 92 billion light years we see
we don't say that it's radius we say
rather it's diameters 92 billion light
years we said its radius is about 46
billion light years so we could see
46 billion light years in each and every
direction why is that well it has to do
with what we spoke about earlier
the universe is expanding so if the
universe was static
right it was just this big thing that
was out there then you're right
the farthest that i could see would be
13 billion light years because
that's how far light could travel in 13
billion years period end of story but
in in a dynamic universe an expanding
universe
light can be emitted from one location
and the source of that light
moves away from us so when i see
that light the actual object
that emitted that light is now further
away because it moved away it could be
45 billion light years away
so i'm seeing it from the moment when it
emitted the light
but its location when i then receive
that signal
is much larger than 13 billion light
years because
it has been moving away while the light
has been traveling to my eyeball
that's the basic idea
all right woody final question i'm going
to do
woody asks i think woody had a question
before it's a double question
sorry for everybody else who didn't get
any in how do you think the universe
will end
how do i think the universe will end
well
i think it's quite likely that the
heat death that we already spoke about
will be
a key moment in the
far future of the universe i do believe
as far as i can tell based on my
understanding of physics
that ultimately planets
will either spiral into their star we
discuss that
earlier from gravitational radiation or
they will wander off into space and then
stars will
supernovas some will turn to black holes
ultimately all of these clumpy objects
will disintegrate
i think it's likely that protons have a
long but
non-zero lifetime before they fall apart
into more fundamental constituents
like pions neutrinos electrons and
things of that sort
and so ultimately all structure will
dissipate into particles
that will spread wider and wider
and it's likely that that will happen on
the order of 10 to the 100 years
so it's a long time you don't have to
worry about it but
in a fundamental sense that is a vital
step now is that the end of the universe
not necessarily
there are weird things that can happen
after that because
when you have a lot of time and you've
got a lot of particles wafting around
and we may have a source of energy
coming from the accelerated expansion of
space yielding a cosmological event
horizon analogous to a black hole event
horizon way out in space
that cosmological event horizon
according to stephen hawking and gary
gibbons
gives off heat in the form of particles
in form of radiation
so we may have a source of radiation
within this large large cosmos
allowing particles to interact
ordinarily most of the time the
particles interact not much will happen
one will bounce off another they'll pass
by each other but on
occasion on rare occasion a couple
particles may stick together
and on rare occasions still clumps
of particles may stick together on rarer
rarer occasions still those particles
may clump together
to yield interesting structures we've
spoken about the possibility in other of
our gatherings
even a human brain may on rare occasions
spontaneously form in the void
so-called boltzmann brain by putting all
those crazy ideas to the side it's also
possible that on rare occasion
the conditions necessary to ignite a new
big bang
may happen so it's not impossible that
the universe may go
through cycles where
the big bang that gave rise to our realm
maybe the conditions necessary for that
rare as they may be may happen again and
so things may start over
we don't know for a fact one way or
another what will happen
sensitive to this question is whether
this accelerated expansion will continue
forever
and thereby have this endless source of
radiation and particles
but that's certainly a possibility for
what may happen
in the very very far future
all right it's about 2 20. i think i'm
gonna wrap it up
for today guys um i enjoyed this
discussion with you all your questions i
enjoyed my conversation with harold
varmus
again my thanks to him for joining us if
you guys have suggestions for people
that
you would like to have me uh in
conversation with
please send them to us you can put them
in the chat you can send them to
the world science festival you can find
our contact information
right on the website or put it just in
the youtube chat
if if you remember to do that later on
or tweet it at
us but we have a number of people lined
up going forward
and i look forward to those
conversations and continue to
address your questions going forward so
keep an eye out for our next session it
may be
next week or the week after we're going
to try to do every week every other week
or so forth but
we'll keep these going and uh i enjoy
your in continued engagement with these
ideas so until
until we meet again take care see you
then